I got asked if you work with Bryan
Cranston on Malcolm in the middle of the
woods for years and you guys have been
remained really good yes
I mean Bryan is honestly like the
greatest human I've ever met like from
the moment I met him I mean even now the
show into 12 years ago 11 years ago was
when we wrapped Malcolm he still reaches
out every month checks in you know if I
need anything you know he's there for me
I yeah awesome so I love him and he's
like honestly like my hero I've always
said that he's somebody what's kind of
cool is that you know he's you know he
played your dad for so many years
probably kind of a mentor I'm imagining
he was giving you advice over the years
yes yes you give us a piece of advice
Bryan Cranston gave you like oh well I
think I can give you a piece of advice
that he gave me that I didn't take okay
five years ago I was at dinner with him
and I was telling all the things I was
doing at the time and he was look I
support you in anything you do just
promise me you won't do Dancing with the
Stars grant it's only been one episode
yeah I honestly love it like I'm mad I
didn't do it sooner
right because they've been asking me for
time and I'm also mad I'm doing it now
because it means I can't do it next year
I think I honestly it's right I didn't
realize I love dancing as much as I do
but have you talked to Brian since you
did since you went against his advice I
was I was gonna I was gonna call him and
you know tell him cuz I thought it would
be you know but then I was like I'll
just let him come to me you'll find you
yeah trust me yeah that guy knows how to
find you yeah
you